hello guys and welcome to another video
since the release of the new doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness
trailer fans have been wondering who are
these other characters in the background
here is this illuminati is this mr
fantastic here according to a new report
it claims that leaks from the sets of
doctor strange and a multiverse of
madness show fan favorite john krasinski
has been cast as mr fantastic in the
film what began as fan casting might
soon be a reality unconfirmed leaks
about upcoming film claim that jon is
set to appear in the film as mr
fantastic a part that fans have lobbied
for him to be cast in marvel comics
introduced debuted version of the
character who resembles doctor there
have been several petitions and even fan
art with john dresses mr fantastic where
nothing official has come from marvel
yet last year certain reports had
claimed that jonah had signed on to play
mr fantastic in the film while his wife
emily blunt has been roped into plays
characters wife sue storm aka invisible
woman however emily was quick to shut
down these rumors in may 2021 speaking
on the howard stern show emily had said
this is a fan carson no one has received
a phone call that's just people saying
wouldn't that be great but such denials
don't mean much to marvel fans anymore
after all andrew garfield repeatedly
denied being a part of spider-man no way
home for two years before eventually
appearing in it fans have been further
emboldened by jones willingness to
appear in doctor strange too i think to
be a part of the marvel world would be
amazing anyway and the fact that people
would even consider me for that level
apart would be amazing doctor told
comicbook.com last year in the comics mr
fantastic is the leader of the fantastic
four which comprises of himself his wife
sue storm brother-in-law joni storm and
ben grimm now like all leaks and rumors
that we speak about on the channel take
this with a grain of salt um i would say
it's actually a good possibility that mr
fantastic will show up in this film
however i would say it may not be john
krasinski you may be a different actor i
guess we'll just have to wait and see
the illuminati is rumored to be in this
film and in this specific scene in the
trailer which shows professor x in the
background here we see a bit of a
council set up and a spot in the middle
which is supposedly for um charles
xavier professor x for him in his
wheelchair mr fantastic is a member of
illuminati so currently everything is
just added up for him to be in this film
but again still taking with a grain of
salt now with this member in the
background here we zoom in here people
saying this is mr fantastic because on
the top of his outfit here looks like
that could be the fantastic four icon to
symbol but honestly i think it's just
too vague to tell people also saying
this could be black panther but honestly
i'm not sure we just have to wait and
see anyway that's about it for this
video so let me know what do you guys
think do you think this is mr fantastic
here or do you think it's someone else
and also if you haven't already please
like and subscribe and turn
notifications on so you don't miss
future videos thanks for watching